Rose wrote in how would libertarianism
address a problem like climate change
depends on how extreme of a libertarian
extreme of a libertarian you are one
argument would be listen businesses have
an inherent incentive to regulate
themselves and no business would pollute
because the publicity would be so bad
that they would go out of business
because nobody would buy their products
which is of course what I call living in
a total fantasy world in part because
it's difficult to attribute the negative
externalities that we know of as
pollution to a particular company
sometimes as you might know pollution
can move around in the atmosphere away
from where it originated and it can
sometimes take a long time to actually
attribute a specific climate impact to a
specific factory for example so the idea
that in a libertarian paradise no one
would pollute because the incentives
would be there that no one would have an
interest in polluting because it'd be
bad for business that's that's
ridiculous and that's been disproven
time and again yeah I think the way to
approach this is to go out there tagline
they always say like you should have the
right to do whatever you want provide
provided that it doesn't affect other
people oh yeah and it's certainly
affecting oh yeah you can definitely
argue that climate change affects other
people unwittingly there are some
libertarians who might be okay with like
a carbon tax based on the damage that
your pollution costs and then the
business would decide is it worthwhile
to pay that like hey you decide that
generating ten kilotons whatever of
pollution is worth it even if you pay
for it because it generates more revenue
for you yeah you might make the business
decision to pay for that amount of
carbon taxes carbon credits whatever but
very quickly you get to the libertarians
who say well no because you need a
central government authority to impose
those and then if you don't pay them
they take you to jail so it's an
initiation of force okay yeah and
libertarians are also in support of
government spending when it comes to
like the military right because that has
to do with our national protection right
and you can argue that climate change is
a national security concern yeah I don't
know if that would get through to them
but I don't think it would do it for
them yeah I would there's actually an
interesting argument
to be made that if taxes are theft
polluting it's theft right some
libertarians say taxes are theft because
we've not consented to be taxed now
there's a number of ways to argue
against that but let's say you buy into
that the negative externalities of
pollution are not something that the
victims of that pollution have consented
to right if you're polluting and hurting
the environment and we're sending living
conditions for people who are just out
in the world and they've not consented
to that isn't that a form of theft of a
shared resource yeah good luck getting a
libertarian to agree with that I think
that this is actually a bigger picture
issue with libertarianism which goes
beyond climate change which is that
strict libertarian dogma is just not
well equipped to deal with negative
externalities period because it is you
have to go through a process to link the
externalities to a cause and that's
where you need some kind of authority to
do that
yeah and libertarians fundamentally are
at odds with that it's interesting cuz
there are a lot of young people who are
libertarians they think they are things
like that the libertarians of today were
Republicans yesterday right in the past
generation
yeah and younger people are all are also
open and accepting of the fact that
climate change is going on yes and I
think there is a decent amount of
overlap there yeah maybe not entirely
but I some there are I would argue that
those people aren't truly libertarians
like there are mostly social
libertarians and they say that they want
as little government intervention in
economics as possible or as reasonable
but very quickly when you when the
rubber hits the road they would come to
realize oh to have a world that looks
like what I want the world to look like
the government's gonna need to be a
little bit more involved than strict
libertarianism would prescribe it but
they also draw a distinction between
anarchy and libertarianism really do
they know that the government needs to
fulfill some services yeah yeah and then
there's a gray area of what what exactly
that would be a big picture this is a
problem for strict libertarian
philosophy